FEMALE SPEAKER:
In Tanzania, women
are waiting to see a health
care worker at an AIDS clinic.
The women are terrified
of being recognized
and fearful that
their husbands will
discover that they have AIDS.
If that happens, the
women fear their husbands
will beat them,
and worse, abandon
them and their children.
In all likelihood,
their husbands
are the ones responsible
for infecting them with HIV.
In a small, dirt floored
room in a Delhi slum, Nezia,
a young Indian woman
is trembling with fear.
She's telling a
woman's support group
how her husband tried
to kill her twice.
He was attempting to
blackmail her family,
because the dowry he received
from them, a motorcycle,
wasn't sufficient.
What he wanted and was
demanding was a full sized car.
My name is [INAUDIBLE], and I'm
an ongoing development program
manager ING tech consumers.
And I'm thrilled to be
introducing you to our speaker
today, Mark Tuschman.
What I just read to you
were two brief excerpts
from a proposal from Mark's
book "Faces of Courage:
Intimate Portraits of
Women on the Edge."
A veteran freelance
photographer, Mark
has traveled to parts of Asia,
Latin America, and Africa
documenting the struggle of
millions of girls and women
to have agency over
their bodies and lives.
Through his
photography, Mark also
chronicles the relentless
doctors, midwives, teachers,
and counsellors
who strive to bring
hope and independence to women.
Mark has devoted much
of the past decade
to collaborating with socially
conscious corporations, UN
agencies, foundations,
and NGOs to document
global health and women's
human rights issues.
Nonetheless, and I think
this is important to say,
this is not a book
about women as victims.
Jill Sheffield of
Women Deliver writes
in the introduction
to "Faces of Courage,"
"Marcus combined sadness with
hope, problem with solution,
and tears with smiles.
We cannot just look
at the problem,
we have to inject hope and
possibility into this reality."
We're thrilled to
have Mark here today.
Please join me in welcoming him.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK TUSCHMAN: Thank you
for the introduction.
I'm very thrilled to be here.
And I really published
"Faces of Courage"
to really help improve the
lives of women and girls,
and to get people to help.
Invariably, I get asked what
motivated me to undertake
this decade long project.
And I earn my living as a
commercial photographer.
And that satisfied my wallet,
but it never satisfied my sense
that photography should be
used to raise consciousness
and promote social justice.
I grew up on the Lower
East Side in New York,
and for the first five
or six years of my life,
I lived in a tenement house with
my grandparents and my parents.
And I don't know if you know
the history of Lower East Side,
but at the turn of last
century, it probably
was the most congested
place on earth.
And it was filled with
great amounts of poverty.
So I think I just became
very sensitized to the issues
of poverty and
people's struggles
to improve their lives.
And in the late
90s, I was reading
a lot of Nicholas
Kristof's columns,
and I became very aware of
the plight of women and girls,
and the struggles they had
every day to just to survive.
And in 2001, I decided
to do something about it
and take some action.
So I had a friend who was
on the board of directors
of the Global Fund
for Women, and she
arranged that I go to Asia, in
particular China, Mongolia--
[AUDIO OUT]
MARK TUSCHMAN:
--acted by the images.
I want the viewer to see these
women as individuals, not just
another statistics,
that their life matters.
They all have dignity, and
each and every one of them
is doing the very, very
best that they can.
This image was
taken in Ethiopia.
And how the women sold
possessions is in this room.
This was in Northern Kenya.
This was a woman
who was a survivor
of the genocidal violence that
occurred in, I think, 2008.
Now having these
series of portraits
allows me to segue into a
very, very important topic,
and that's the whole issue
of maternal health care.
In fact, every time a
woman or a young girl
gets pregnant in a
developing country,
she's risking her life.
And I've come across
many scenes like this--
this one is in
northern Nigeria--
where all these
women are waiting
to see not a doctor or a nurse,
but a health care worker.
And they've had to overcome
many, many obstacles to just
even get to this clinic.
There are financial obstacles,
there's lack of facilities,
there's cultural and
religious obstacles,
many, many obstacles.
And this was another
scene in northern Nigeria,
and all these women
are just sitting
in this dirt floor waiting
to see a traditional birth
attendant.
And this is their total sum
of their medical facilities
in this little room.
Now without contraception
or medical care,
teenagers get pregnant at
a very, very early age,
unfortunately, and
basically, confining them
to a endless cycle of poverty
with very, very little choices
in their life.
This young woman
is from Ethiopia,
and she's 17 years old,
and that's the second child
that she has on her back.
This photograph was
taken in Bangladesh,
and it was in a ward with
a lot of teenage mothers.
And here, you can see the
mother's in the background.
She's completely
detached from her child.
And this was very, very common.
It's the nurse who's
taking care of her baby.
This was taken last
year in Meru, Kenya.
That's Frieda on your right.
And she's 16 years old.
It's her first baby,
a baby out of wedlock.
Now one of the consequences
of teenage pregnancy
is that without
reproductive health care,
many teenagers are too
immature to really have a baby
and they'll have an
obstructed labor and they'll
develop a fistula.
And for those of
you who don't know,
a fistula is a tear between
a woman's vagina and either
a rectum or urethra.
And the consequences are
really pretty devastating.
She will just be leaking
urine or feces uncontrollably.
And unless it's
treated surgically,
she'll be ostracized, and
her life will be a nightmare.
And there's about a
million young girls,
as far as I know, that
have untreated fistulas,
even though the
fistula surgery's, I
think, about $50 to $100 and
could easily be repaired.
And this was in Malawi.
This is Margarito, and
she's had her surgery
or is waiting for her surgery.
And she's 15 years old.
She had an obstructed delivery.
Her baby died, but at least
she was fortunate enough
to get to this clinic
and get a repair.
Now it turns out that females
are really the face of AIDS.
They're much more susceptible
to getting AIDS than males.
And this was Ana, and she was
mentioned in the introduction.
And this was in Tanzania.
And again, just to repeat, she
was just terrified of telling
her husband that she
had AIDS, because she
would be just thrown out of her
home, have no shelter, no food,
even though he's the
one who gave it to her.
And she was even terrified
to be seen with a film crew.
We had to go into a
small, little room,
so her neighbors
wouldn't even see her.
And this was taken in Kenya.
That's Ruth and
her daughter, Jane.
And this is in one of
the slums in Nairobi,
and they both have AIDS,
but fortunately they're
being treated with anti-virals.
And they have no symptoms.
Now there's a big
chapter in the book where
I give homage to all
the health care workers,
because to me they're the
silent heroes of the book.
They just work relentlessly
and for very, very little pay.
They go to all these
rural communities.
They're really on
the front of giving
maternal reproductive
health care.
This was in Otavalo, Ecuador.
Now there's a big section
on the book on contraception
and family planning.
And let me explain
this photograph to you.
It's very special.
It's really the
only thing I've ever
documented that
really demonstrated
actual cultural change.
This was in northern Nigeria.
And this was an Evangelical
Christian church.
And they really had
this very strong beliefs
that contraception and
family planning was taboo,
but there was an amazing
Planned Parenthood
officer that worked with the
unlikely name of Thankguy
[? Okesen ?], and he
worked with them for years.
And he got them to
change their policies.
And here they are, and
this is the congregation
in the background.
And they have all these
different contraceptives
that they're handing
out, and they've really
adopted these practices,
which is pretty amazing.
And they're very
serious about it,
because even when you
go to a hairdresser,
they'll hand out a condom
just in case you need one.
There's a chapter in the book
on peer sexual education.
And I don't know, but you
haven't seen many scenes
like this in the United States.
And it's a very
successful program.
This isn't Cusco, Peru,
and that's Ophelia.
And she's in front of her
parents' boarding house,
and she's just, basically,
handing out a contraceptive
to a student who's
boarding at their house
and explaining its safe usage.
So anyway, the next
part of the book,
it really is the most
emotionally difficult part,
and it's all about
violence against women.
And even though a lot
of these photographs
were taken in India, the
violence against women
really is pervasive.
It's all over the world.
And this is Kala, and she's the
cover of "Faces of Courage",
and she's a child bride.
This was in Rajasthan, India.
And she was married when
she was three months old,
which is hard to believe.
I sometimes have to repeat that.
And the deed was
signed, and she's still
living at home with her parents,
but as soon as she's old enough
to have a child, which will be
shortly, she was about maybe 13
when I took these photos,
she's going to be shipped off
to her husband's home.
And while I was
photographing Kala,
her neighbor Mooney walked in.
And it turned out that Mooney
was married when she was 15,
but when she was 16,
her husband died.
And then she explained
to me that now she's
a widow for life,
which I also found
rather stunning, shocking.
And she's considered
bad luck in her culture.
Nobody will marry her now.
This is a section
on dowry abuse.
And this is Nazia.
And she's here in
Delhi, and she's
telling her story of
how her husband tried
to kill her not once, but
twice, because the dowry wasn't
sufficient.
And dowries, even though
the British outlawed it
when they were still
in charge of India,
it's still very, very widely
practiced more than ever.
And dowries just, basically,
a continual system
of ongoing blackmail.
And a husband who wanted a
car instead of the motorcycle,
and it wasn't sufficient, so he
pushed her off the motorcycle
while she was pregnant,
and she he lost a baby.
And he went to get
her in the hospital,
and he tried to
poison her again.
And the only support
she really has
is to go into this
women's group.
And she's trying to
really get permission
to really get divorced.
I took this portrait
of her after she
was talking to
the group, and you
can see how tense she is just
in the gesture in her hands,
and she immediately broke
into tears afterwards.
And it took a lot of courage
for her even to come to this
group to present her case.
This is Rachna, and
this was Lucknow, India.
And she had had a baby, and
there were some complications,
so she had to stay in the
hospital a bit longer.
And when she came home,
her husband and her in-laws
told her it really
wasn't her baby,
and they beat and
threw in a closet
and tried to really beat her
badly, and she had to escape.
And the husband,
basically, was using
her to get a baby,
because the woman he
wanted to have a baby
with couldn't have a baby.
Again, I got most of these
stories through NGOs,
and a lot of them were supported
by a Global Fund for Women.
And this was another case.
This is Mira, and
again, this was Lucknow.
And she was found
wandering the streets
just sobbing and crying.
And she went to the
police originally,
and the police asked
her what's the problem.
And she said, well, her
mother's a sex worker,
and her mother was
beating her, because he
wanted her to go
into the business
and drop out of school.
And she didn't want to.
And the police
said to her, well.
You should just be a good girl
and listen to your mother.
We'll even be your clients.
It was only through
the intervention an NGO
that she was able to
get back to school.
And she's living now with
her aunt and uncle, who
are her guardians right now.
But in the book,
there are stories
of women who have had similar
experiences with the police.
And I even recorded one
story of a woman who
was married to a police
officer, and she had no recourse
with the legal system at all.
There's a chapter in
the book on trafficking.
And this is Sanni.
And this was taken in Indonesia.
And Indonesia traffics 6
million women ostensibly
as domestic
servants, and she was
held in Saudi Arabia
for three years
without being able to
communicate with her family.
And again, it was
only an NGO that
was able to gain
her freedom and have
her reunited with their
family, And you see them
in the background.
And while I was
interviewing her,
I just couldn't
imagine what it was
like for them to be
separated for three years,
not knowing at all
if she was alive.
It's just terrible.
And unfortunately, it's
not a very uncommon story.
So we're going to
switch gears now.
I'm going to try and
tell you about some
of the more positive aspects.
This is a big chapter
on economic empowerment
and rehabilitation.
And this is Jolie.
And this was in Nairobi, Kenya.
And this was a program
called Heshima Kenya,
and it was sponsored by
American Jewish World Service.
And Heshima Kenya
basically takes young girls
from war torn countries in
Central and Eastern Africa,
and almost all of
them have been subject
to physical and sexual violence,
and they rehabilitate them.
And Jolie's become a very
successful textile artist.
She's able to support herself.
She has a new community.
And I'm not going to go
into her whole story.
I didn't get her story
until about two months
after I photographed her.
But when I read her
story, in my mind,
she was like one of the greatest
examples of human resilience
I've ever read about.
She was originally from
Rwanda, and just horrible,
horrible things happened to her.
And I actually chose
to photograph her,
because she had so
much joy in life.
And I just couldn't imagine this
was really the same person who
had endured so much tragedy.
This is [? Royta ?].
She was a former
fistula patient.
And this was in Dar
Es Salaam, Tanzania,
and it's another program that's
used to rehabilitate women.
And she's a textile artist.
I have a big section in
the book on microfinance,
and this was in Ghana.
And this is Sarah,
who was a very, very
successful entrepreneur.
And she took a small loan of $50
and was able to take more loans
and grow a very successful
bakery business where she bakes
3,000 loaves of bread a week.
And she employs many people.
And she's able to send
her children to school,
and she's making sure
they get a full education.
This was in Gujarat, India.
This is Kurivan.
And it's sort of an example of
how maybe traditional education
doesn't work for all people,
but there are other methods that
are really empowering women.
And Kurivan is very
tribal, as you can see.
And it turns out that
a lot of these tribes
in the Kutch region a Gujarat
have tremendous textile skills.
And a woman, Judy Frater, came
over there and started an NGO.
And she taught these women
marketing skills and design
skills.
So instead of just doing
rote trite work for tourists,
they actually can do very
high end creative work,
and they can sell
their work in high end
boutiques in Mumbai and Delhi
and even export them to Europe.
And it was wonderful to see
the work they were doing.
They were very excited
to be doing the work.
They make a good livelihood.
And so I think
every solution has
to be addressed
to the population
that you're trying to improve.
It's not one shoe fits all.
Now the biggest section of the
book is on girls' education.
And really nothing gives
me more hope and optimism
than when I walk into
a classroom of girls,
and I see and feel
their enthusiasm,
and just their intensity to
learn is just really palpable.
And I'm just going to go
through a few examples.
This is a program in
India, again, in Rajastan.
And in Rajastan, the
illiteracy rate of girls
is particularly high.
And also, they have very, very
high child marriage rates.
And Educate Girls
India, they're really
trying to get girls
educated and keep them
from getting married
as young brides.
And this is Priya.
And she was the very first young
girl that I photographed there.
And unfortunately,
she really had
to stay home and take care
of the goats and her younger
siblings, but her neighbor,
Nishi, is with her mother.
And her mother had
a chance when she
was younger to travel
outside of her village,
and she realized that she would
have a completely different
life had she been educated.
And she is ensuring that
her daughter is really
getting a full education now.
And this is
[? Payelle ?], and she's
13 years old in maybe
sixth or seventh grade.
She's not a child bride.
She's in school.
There's many, many
more photographs
of this program in the book.
Now the microfinance
program in Ghana
also has a girls'
education project,
and they give scholarships to
100 of the best and brightest
girls in their community.
This was in northern Nigeria,
and this was a program,
I think, run by the
Bixby school out of UCSF.
And these photographs were taken
in a small, little mud hut.
It was raining, it was
muddy when we got there.
They had to sweep out the
water and put down a mat.
And a teacher basically
comes once a week.
And they have a little book,
and all these girls just
take turns reading
from this one book.
And they just follow
every word, every sentence
that each one of them is saying.
Now I thought they were really
engaged until the teacher
brought out a computer.
And I've never seen more
fascination, more focused
attention than anywhere.
And to me, it's
really a great example
of how potential is
everywhere, but opportunity
is lacking in most places.
This is Lynnette and Sharon,
and their Massai girls,
and this was in southern Kenya.
And this was another
girls' education project.
And it turns out that
Massai girls are also
forced to marry when
they're very, very young,
and even undergo the
barbaric tradition
of female genital mutilation.
And American Jewish
World Service
is trying to educate
these young Massai girls,
and I really believe it's
having an effect in changing
the culture.
There's a section in
the book on young women
who have grown up in very,
very difficult circumstances,
and through the help
of NGOs and foundations
have made successful
careers for themselves.
And this is [? Ferita ?],
and she's an English teacher
in Dar Es Salaam, Tanzania.
And she's here with
part of her class.
Her class had about
150 students that
could hardly walk around
and move around in it.
Now I end the book with
another series of portraits,
and that's of young girls.
And I really like the statement
of purpose of the United
Nations Population
Fund, and that's
every pregnancy
should be wanted,
and every child birth safe, and
every young person's potential,
especially those of young
girls, should be fulfilled.
Now you look at these young
girls, and they're full of joy,
and they have absolutely no idea
of the dangers that await them.
They're really
literally on the edge.
They're on the edge of
getting an education,
being able to make
choices for themselves.
Or are they going to face
some of these horrible things
that I mentioned earlier,
teenage pregnancy
and fistula and physical
and sexual violence.
It's really up to us
to really make sure
that they have a life that's
really full of potential.
And many people have told
me that "Faces of Courage"
is a very, very timely book.
And my response to them
is that unfortunately, I
feel it's going to be
timely for far too long
into the foreseeable future.
And I really published
"Faces of Courage"
to raise consciousness
and bring this issue
to the world's attention.
And it's really
my hope to really
get this book into high
school and college libraries,
really to educate and create
a whole new set of activists,
because I really feel young
people are very visually
oriented, and they respond
to compelling images.
They're great at
social media, and I
believe they'll be a great
energy source to us, spread
the word that the rights
of women and girls
should be ensured
every place on earth.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I guess we can take
some questions now.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
It's really touching to
see all those pictures.
And honestly, I get very
heavy hearted and overwhelmed.
And I'm wondering if you have
any specific advice over how
we can make a difference,
because the problem feels
too big.
MARK TUSCHMAN: I think that's
the most common question
I really get asked.
And it is a big problem.
And the only way to
really address it
is really on a personal level.
Everyone has a different
set of talents.
I happen to be a photographer,
so I've approached it that way.
But there are people who
are great fundraisers,
great communicators.
There are people who
may have the ambition
to start their own NGO.
In the back of the book,
there are all the NGOs
that I know of that I worked
for that are collaborated with,
and you can get involved
with any one of them,
and they'd probably be able
to volunteer to get started.
But it is a big
problem, and it requires
a lot of people really
getting involved.
And it's hard.
It's hard to really good
attention on this matter.
I mean, just look at what's
happening in the world
right now.
Everything is about all that the
terrorists, and rightfully so.
But there's really
a correlation,
because it turns out
that all these places
where you have all these
religious fanatics,
they're the places that treat
women the absolute worst.
So it's very important
to empower women
as a way of combating
terrorism, too.
AUDIENCE: I'd like
to ask perhaps more
technical questions about
the photography side.
MARK TUSCHMAN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Seems like, obviously,
you make a good connection
with the gals,
because of the smiles
and the genuine portrayals.
Could you talk about that
process, language barriers,
how do you approach it,
how does it work out?
MARK TUSCHMAN: That's also the
second most asked question.
But years ago, I
was with my son.
He's an anthropologist.
And I was photographing
with him in Peru.
And he said, "Dad, how do
you get these pictures?
You're not communicating
with these people."
So I really had to
think about that.
I really had to reflect.
I really couldn't
answer right away.
What I came up with, I
think it's just the energy
that I have when I'm
photographing anyone,
especially some of
these women and girls.
Well, first of all, it took
10 years to do the project.
And one of the reasons
it took so long
was that I always
had to collaborate
with the NGO or foundation.
I just couldn't
get on an airplane
and just go off by
myself, because I really
needed to be accepted
into the communities.
And the way to do it
is to go with people
that-- first of all, I want
to record the work of NGOs
and foundations.
But I also wanted to gain
the trust of the people
that I'm photographing.
So just coming in with
people that they know
and that they've developed
a relationship with,
that really helps.
So some of that trust must
get transferred to me.
But I also think
it's my attitude.
A lot of people-- I
teach photography,
and lots of times
people who are not
used to photographing people
are kind of nervous and tense.
They don't want to
bother the people,
they want to get it as
quickly as they can.
Well, people are
picking up your energy,
so I go in with the
attitude that I'm
going to do something special.
We're going to take
our time if possible.
And you're important
to me, and we're
going to try and
create something
that tells your story in your
really classic, beautiful way.
So I think people
just pick up my energy
that I'm really
serious and intense,
and I think I'm fairly
calm when I'm doing this,
and that I care.
AUDIENCE: What are
the time frames?
MARK TUSCHMAN: Boy, I have
to actually work really fast.
Sometimes I have some
time, but lots of times
I have to work very, very fast.
And I just have a
lot of experience,
so I know how to do it.
I always like to have more time,
but it's usually with an NGO,
and they have an itinerary,
and we have to just move
from place to place.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Thank you for speaking
today and sharing with us
all of these beautiful
images that you've really
used to capture so much more
than just the photographs
that we can see.
So I'm wondering how you
capturing all of these women
and children has changed
your idea of what photography
is capable of.
MARK TUSCHMAN: I've always
felt that photography
can be used to really raise
consciousness and promote
social justice.
Just getting back to my
experience growing up
on Lower East Side
was I changed careers
to become a photographer.
And I don't know if you know
the work of like Lewis Hines
and Jacob Riis, they
documented all--
I was very attracted them,
cause they were documenting
all the life of all the
immigrants on the Lower East
Side.
And there are many photographers
who's work does make an impact.
I think the trouble right
now is that it's almost
like an overabundance
of media, and it's
easy for very, very
good stuff to get lost.
And I really think
that's your real problem.
I think we're just over
bombarded by too much media.
And I think it's a
really big question
about how do you break through.
I'd love for the book to
get much wider distribution
and become people become
much more aware of it,
but maybe that's where
you guys can help with
all your social media skills.
But I do think photographs
to make a difference.
And they make a difference
when they're very personal.
What is it?
A month, six weeks
ago, I forget,
there was a photograph of
a little Syrian boy who
died off the coast of Turkey.
And all of a sudden, when
that photograph was published,
there was just a great
uproar about the rights
of the refugees.
And I really think it was
such an effective photograph,
because it had a very
personal element.
When people see a lot
of images of masses
of people and everything,
we throw up our hands,
we don't know what to
do, it's like too much.
In my work, and I think
what that photographer did,
he tried to make
it really personal.
So you have a sense of
empathy and compassion.
You can relate to the
people that you're seeing.
So I think good
photography will do that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you again.
So this is actually
very close to me.
I grew up in Rajasthan in an
all girls boarding school.
And I know girls wouldn't come
back from summer vacation,
and the reasons I heard was
because they were married.
So I relate to a lot of this.
My own wedding was called off
two months before the first day
I was supposed to get mine,
because of dowry demand,
so I relate to all
of this very closely.
I've actually taken
the next summer off.
I now have a
12-year-old daughter.
And to basically show
her how privileged she is
and to go back to India
and Spain this summer
and actually working
with these NGOs,
I'm having a hard time
finding the right place
to go to, because maybe it's
easier for you, because you
have a name.
But for me, how do I begin?
How do I find a safe place?
MARK TUSCHMAN: I can help you.
I can give you the names
of some contacts in India.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MARK TUSCHMAN: OK?
I'll be glad to
help you, especially
ones that work in Rajasthan.
This Educate Girls
India, I'll just
put you in touch with them.
[APPLAUSE]